je propose à la rame ion de prendre la
parole oui merci
concernant la traduction c'est déballe
ses débats d'ailleurs ont été très riche
en enseignements je vis de me présenter
la ramillon conseillère départementale
de mulhouse 3
comme l'a rappelé rémi bertrand et comme
l'a également rappelé mme greff eckert
avec passion nous sommes attachés au
droit local d'alsace moselle et nous
sommes aussi et défenseurs de ce droit
local alors j'avais envie mais bien sûr
le président éric straumann l'a dit non
ce n'est pas une coquille vide parce que
généralement nous ne remplissons pas la
coquille avant de concerter c'est quand
même mieux d'abord de se concerter et
ensuite de remplir la co qui totalement
sinon ce n'est plus de la démocratie
alors oui aujourd'hui ce rapport prouve
notre stratégie commune et notre volonté
d'être pragmatique et unis le bon sens
aujourd'hui doit conduire toutes nos
actions
les citoyens ne veulent plus entendre
des positions partisanes qui polluent
les débats et l'efficacité il est
évident comme vous l'avez tous rappelé
qu'un travail d'actualisation et
d'harmonisation et de sanctions comme
j'ai entendu des statuts département
relatif à l'ouverture des commerces les
dimanches et jours fériés en alsace doit
être mis en place
j'ai également entendu monsieur morère
qui nous rappelait que la coopération
avec la moselle doit aussi bien surpris
mais il est évident que nous mènerons
une large concertation d'ailleurs le
rapport les cris bien
il donne quelques exemples notamment
avec mais lorsqu'on écrit notamment avec
c'est à dire que l'on peut faire d'autre
concertation ce que nous allons bien sûr
faire avec la commission du droit local
que milla était proposée par les
présidents moi surtout je me réjouis de
travail en commun que nous allons
réaliser sur ce dossier et sur les
autres dossiers qui viennent d'être
traités je trouve que c'est le
but d'une belle aventure commune qu'il
nous appartient d'inscrire dans une
démarche d'efficience pour l'alsace
c'est pourquoi je vous demande
d'approuver ce rapport